buddy yeah I am so fucking tired right now as you guys know
I haven't slept yet um I checked down two coffees but I'm
here I need to update you guys on life and Latoki what the
fuck do you mean you haven't slept okay I okay first off
there's two reasons
again because I fucked it up by working and then too I had a
lot of work so so it's like you know you know you know when
you're you know if you were like you know a pre-debut vtuber
usually get you know a couple of months I didn't get I
didn't have the luxury of a couple of months to come back
like i don't know you know a couple of days so i'm like i'm
like speed running stuff right now so yeah there's there's
just there's a lot but hey it's crazy we have like we hit
monetize i was so surprised that we hit monetization we
actually okay i didn't tell the story because like We
actually hit monetization like like like being applicable to
apply for monetization before my first stream Also, oh my
god.
Thank you all for the super chats.
Holy shit.
Thank you everybody.
My chat died There you go.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Um, oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh my chat's fucking dead.
There's just too much stuff going on My chat has died now.
Okay.
All right.
Whatever.
Anyway.
Um, but yes.
So like I was applicable to apply for monetization before I
even started my first stream.
And then after my first stream.
Okay.
Not even first.
Sorry.
My return stream.
I forgot.
There's other videos on this channel.
But anyway.
After my return stream was done.
Like an hour.
two later um i hit the uh they're like you're monetized i
was like yay but there was a fucking catch because whoever
you were that fucking played free bird in the middle of my
stream anyway all proceeds of my return stream now goes to
free bird zone you know what all right to be fair i had the
option to mute freebird but i had to it was basically like
if i mute freebird uh we won't have the live chat replay i
felt like okay this is my first stream return stream back so
if i have a return stream back i feel like we need to chat
replay because I figured I found out I was like what a fuck
is where's my live chat replay so basically if you try to
mute even I thought it was like if you edit the vibe you
lose your live chat but apparently if you mute your vibe or
like anything regarding muting or replacing the audio it
counts as removing the live chat so I was just like all
right we'll just You know what?
Oh, you deserve the money.
It's fine.
You deserve it.
I was just like, it's fine.
How did it play?
Well, I haven't touched the settings on my stream labs for a
very long time.
And I forgot when I used to stream on Twitch, I had people
submit like audio, they can submit audio clips.
Or you guys can't do that here now because I replaced my
alert box to my my youtube now so the alert box is not
connected to my stream like not connected to my twitch
stream labs anymore so now you can't fucking play free birds
on stream anymore so this bot won't get demonetized i hope
so we don't have to worry about demonetization via free
birds so yeah i can't believe i got this is exactly why i am
but we were never gonna be free birds we're going to be
fucking free birds because my return stream is demonetized
um but yeah oh my god there has been i've been doing so much
stuff okay so it was a little bit naive of me to think that
like i was like man 50 orders is going to be a lie i was
like oh my god if i get like just a 50 orders in the merch
store that'll be good enough for me little do i know it was
a little bit over 50 you know it was like i literally put up
the limited bundle for like less than five minutes and it
was just gone I was like what I refreshed it I was like huh
wait wait what and then by the way it was I sorry I've like
shot myself in the foot there because like the personalized
messages is that I was I was gonna write like each postcard
was gonna be like a unique message from me and then now I'm
like okay it's a hundred postcards be fine i can just do
this like like it'll be a build-up but then i'm loud now
it's 200 so now it's 200 oh my god okay we'll make it
through um but yes this is like my first time opening my own
big store so like it was so fucking naive of me to think
that i was like okay um we can Because you know how you guys
might think, oh, she must have been planning on opening a
store, like, since, like, five days.
I don't know.
When did I lost my job?
Sorry.
You know, like, you know, that day.
But no, it was literally two hours.
Two hours before...
Two hours before my return stream.
Um, I was like, Mr. Man, I don't have time to prep for my
return stream and do my store.
Can you do the store?
And Mr. Man was like, yeah, I think I can do it.
And I was like, Mr. Man, do you think you can get it done
while I'm streaming?
And he was like, yeah.
And little did we know running a store and getting a...
Running a store?
Well, not knowing how...
How many people are actually buying the products?
It was, it took longer than, you know, it definitely took
much longer than four hours to set everything up.
In fact, it's crazy that we even managed to set all of this
up within three days.
So, um, so like, okay, so when we launched it, for some
reason, the shipping thing, yeah, how hard.
could it be you know it was it was pretty difficult I it was
it was pretty difficult like yeah it was it was okay so you
know store launched and then we realized the shipping was
like connected to like the ship when you buy a sticker for
some fucking reason the shipping for stickers was like 20
and i was like wait that's not right i was like i was like
uh mr man i'm getting reports that shipping is 20 for a
sticker and then it was my decision to pull the story down
immediately after we figured found out because like mr man
was like oh yeah we can try and fix it while the story is
still up I was like no shut it down now we need to fix this
because like I think like at first we thought it was gonna
be a quick fix but then like we realized wait this is not a
quick fix and I didn't want to I really like I really didn't
want to like um overcharge people on shipping as well
because like uh I know how much shipping costs and I just I
just didn't want to overcharge you guys for like these items
because like you know you're willing to buy from me and
you're willing to like spend your money on me and everything
and like I don't want to fucking like um overcharge you on
the shipping I wanted like a fair price and then mr.
man was like you might have a loss if you don't know exactly
like like the shipping thing and I was like I rather I'd
rather take a tiny loss in shipping um or instead of like
overcharging all of you guys uh in shipping and getting like
a like a necessary profit from the shipping itself um so I
wanted to make it as fair as possible because I've like
shipped props I should yeah I shipped products uh since I
was a middle schooler and like I've sold things middle
school or so i know like the exact prices of actual like uh
postal costs and everything so like because like um
sometimes like the weight doesn't really correlate with like
how much it actually costs at the post office so i knew like
like i because i had experience shipping things i knew like
yeah that's not the actual like price with the weight and
like i cause like the charms It was like one charm like on
the website one charm it made it for Canadian shipping it
was like $19 Canadian and I was like okay that's not right I
was just like I was just like wait a minute it should not be
$19 for one charm I was like okay wait a minute but then I
was like yeah that's a problem originally the um the bundles
was like sixty dollars I was like wait a minute I know for
sure it is not sixty dollars I was like in the United States
because like it's like a don't keep a crew cover with like
an acrylic charm and acrylic stand I was like, there's no
fucking way it's $60 to the United States.
I was like, I've shipped these before.
I, there's no, unless Canadian Canada Post is like fucking
bankrupt.
Like, like inflation in the past two to three years, like,
okay, the Canadian dollar is fucking garbage, but it's not
that bad where it takes 60 fucking dollars to send to
America.
Like, at that point, why the fuck are we living in Canada?
Like, at that point, we should, like, not even sell anything
to the States because it's not even worth it.
Um, uh, but yeah, anyway, so we had all, so that's why it
took us, like, four to, uh, four to five hours, because we
have to go through, like, individually of, like, all, all
the items to make sure um to make sure everything was like
reasonable um everything no stop insulting canada look look
all canadians including myself will agree with me um anyways
so like we've accepted we've accepted our place in the world
um but yeah so like i tried really hard and then And then
after the shop went back live, my mom came in and was like,
was like, you're shipping is too cheap.
My mom came in.
I was like, what are you doing?
What if, what if it's too cheap?
And I was like, no, don't worry.
I don't worry.
Um, but yes, so we've expanded.
uh we've expanded our team our uh mr man team so now we have
mr man little man and consult man so like we at first so it
was gonna be mr man and little man and little man was
recruited because they have experience running uh shopify um
and so and they wrote like all the terms of and are doing
customer support and like the privacy policy they wrote all
of that and then so then but then when we did our first
launch uh the first launch that was at 12 uh we realized
that like there were problems there were issues with like
worldwide shipping and um and everything so then we uh mr
man recruited consult man so consult man um is also used to
work at Shopify and they also like was helping us figure out
why we weren't doing we weren't able to have worldwide
shipping as well as like like you know like the credit card
issue apparently for those who are wondering why your your
country isn't in um isn't uh in like the shipping stuff yet
it's like it's like a gradual thing so later on they'll like
you'll it's like a Shopify thing so later on more and more
countries will be like eligible um so it just takes a
gradual time um and i want to say like a huge thank you to
the team because they're working incredibly hard and they're
like updating everybody on um they're like updating
everybody uh on uh twitter as well like emails for anyone
that had questions like and anything and they're like
updating on like on real time too So, they're trying to make
sure everybody receives their order and everything.
And also, like, during those times, they, like, refunded
everybody that accidentally paid the $20 shipping for one
sticker.
They, like, refunded, oh, my God.
They, like, refunded, like, oh, my gosh, wait, actually, I
can see it right now, how many orders they had to refund.
Because, like, we didn't want to, like, scam anybody.
I know some of you guys are like, no, take my...
Overpriced fucking shipping.
No, please.
I realize, no, don't do that to yourself.
Please love yourself like I eventually did.
But like we refunded like 480 orders that accidentally paid
way too much than it should be and everything.
By the way, I also thank you again, everybody, for the super
chat.
I can't believe it.
For those who are wondering why I haven't opened up
memberships yet.
Oh, sorry.
Ambership.
Sorry, for those who are wondering why I haven't opened
Amber Ships yet.
It is because I had to do this.
I had to do the merch stuff.
So there's a lot of work into getting everything for the
Amber Ships.
So I couldn't, I didn't really have the time to because I
had to write a lot of stuff.
And I was like, oh my god, there's not enough time.
There's not enough time right now.
But anyway.
Um, fuck.
What was the story before?
Fuck.
Okay.
Anyway, regarding the story, uh, the funny thing is that,
oh, no, he's not funny, but like, okay, it's a little funny.
I was like freaking out because I am a huge perfectionist.
So I was like, what the fuck is going on?
And I was like, why are they paying $20 for shipping for a
fucking sticker?
And then like, I was like, take the site down.
Now I don't want to scam.
I don't want to want to I don't want to scam anybody like um
they gave so much to me I don't want I want to make sure
everything is fair and then um and then I was like I was
like like like I'm sorry Mr. Man for for being so harsh like
I was just very overwhelmed and I also did not sleep at all
and then um you know what Mr. Man said Mr. Man was like
don't worry I managed xqc this is nothing
he's like no matter what i'll never reach that level so i
was just like oh shit you know what you're right no matter
what i say to you you've already been hardened by your time
managing xqc he doesn't manage him anymore he used he used
to be his manager so i was just like i was just like you
know what you're right no matter what i would never i would
never be as bad when it comes to that um so so i was like oh
thank god anyway uh the team i'm just really thankful
because mr match has like a lot of experience and a lot of
like uh a lot of like i guess like experience and
connections and everything because uh when we brought in
consult man because i was like i was like no the shipping
the shipping has to be cheaper i can't deal with i know
because at first after we got rid of 20 we went with 17 and
then i was like no that is still too expensive but it was on
the shopify thing like the the shopify was like defaulting
to that and then um and then i was and then they're like but
it's gonna be a loss i was like no i know stickers are not
fucking 17 dollars because it's literally paper where the
fuck is the weight in fucking paper so then um consultant
man was helping with like the shopify thing and then they're
like no you have like and then when like i had so many
questions and stuff like Consultman actually works for
Ludwig And they're like Don't worry, Consultman has
experience And now it's like, yeah But Ludwig doesn't sell
VTuber products
I was like I don't think Ludwig sells VTuber products And I
know paper is not $17
so um like so like i was like please trust me on this like i
know you work for ludwig but please trust me on this it has
to be two or three dollars because like it's paper
um so that's why now like uh the stickers are for shipping
is uh what could it be was based ah yes the ludwig daki
makura that i don't know i don't know about that um so yes
the it is it is a team but i really do appreciate i really
do appreciate the man team being made and uh and mr man
recruiting uh to very very very talented individuals that
definitely know what they're doing they fucking open a store
in three days that's like despite some scuff um and like you
know some bugs and stuff um this is the first time we like
open like for me i open something like this so um like i've
done like small scale so like i've never done something this
big and like yes graphic design is mr man's passion uh but i
swear it will look like a real website soon we just didn't
have the time to set that up um so like at first uh mr man
made the header and it just says no head because the the er
got cut off and then my my friend One of my friends sent me
a screenshot and was like, what the fuck?
Why does this seem real bad?
I was just like, oh, fuck.
Wait, can't let us fix that real quick?
But yes, now, now it says no header.
Don't worry.
We're family friendly, as could be.
We're not too kid friendly so that I still am monetized, but
we are PG-13.
We're PG-13.
Uh, also, thank you guys so much for the super chats.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everybody, for the Akasupas.
It really, really, really means so much, guys.
Thank you, everybody, for the support.
Oh, my God.
Um, but yeah, it's been like, it's been so crazy.
I, oh, it's been like so fucking crazy.
of days I've been like non-stop working I've recently just
hired um some editors that would start uh working on um
shorts again um I'm reaching out to some animators um I
finished my schedule yesterday night that's one of the
reason why I haven't slept I was um finishing up my schedule
yesterday night and uh and oh my god there's so many things
there's so many things I have to do for Mr. Man as well.
There's so many things.
There's, I wish I could tell you guys what the fuck is going
on behind the scene.
I wish I could.
There's, like, so many things I really want to talk to you
guys.
But there's, there's, like, so many sponsors and, like,
conventions, like, people that reached out.
And I, like, cried last night.
I, I, I, I cried last night because the support.
okay to be fair i cried every i cry every day after
everything i went through i like cry every day but like last
night i cried like happy tears because i was just so like
overwhelmed with everything and overwhelmed with all the
support and it was just crazy like all the things all the
opportunities and everything I really I really did not
expect all these opportunities just um like of all these
opportunities of people reaching out to me it was just it
was just crazy and then oh my gosh and then like like mr man
was like um oh because I was like thank you again to Mr.
Manfred like doing all of this and because like you know he
this isn't even his like managing me isn't even his like
main job he he's like doing this like on the side for me but
he's already giving like he gave like five hours like
non-stop of trying to fix the store and bring in two very
talented individuals to help settle everything for the store
and like communicating with people and everything regarding
like like their orders and all that stuff and um you know
this isn't even his like main job i was just like and then
he's like i was like thank you again and he's like um i was
like um i like you as a person and i'll give you my 110 and
i'm like
like why why um but yeah it's actually it's it's been so
fucking crazy oh sorry i had to like calm down a little bit
to calm down oh my god i know so you guys are like Where's
our gaming stream?
Another!
Zatzodon, another chatting...
Guys, soon.
Soon.
As I said, our first gaming stream is going to be Neopets.
Guys, don't worry.
That's going to be happening next week.
Tomorrow, we will be celebrating Lunar New Year.
I think it's going to be at 5 p.m.
PST tomorrow.
We're going to be celebrating Lunar New Year.
And then then, I think I'll be opening my membership
tomorrow as well.
because I want to do Garfield Cart next week.
I want to do Garfield Cart next week in members.
So I really, I really want to open my membership by then so
we can play Garfield Cart.
And yeah, like, there's just, there's so many things going
on.
But yes, thank you everybody for the super chat.
Thank you.
everyone for the support and thank you everybody for just ah
it's just crazy it's still it's still super surreal and
everything um that's going on and also for those who are
like are we getting our names yet are we going to are we
going to be finally named um no I'm sort of enjoying guys
like battle royaling out right now and like fighting each
other on which is the name to represent you guys and also
like I feel like I'm way too tired to pick a name today I
did not I did not really have a chance to like actually look
through all the names so I'm going to give you guys one more
day and tomorrow on lunar new year yes you guys are nameless
for another day so you guys are nameless for another day you
guys still have to fight each other for one more day because
by God I love seeing you all fight
but tomorrow we're gonna not only decide the name but also
we are going to be finally I'm gonna draw you guys we're
gonna draw a mascot a fan mascot to represent all of you
tomorrow as well so that's what to look forward to you know
what I'll tell you guys my schedule i've fucking worked all
night on it yesterday night so i might as well tell you guys
my schedule anyway so um obviously uh we're gonna have
neopets on i'm taking sunday off because holy fuck i hope i
reset my schedule by then but uh monday is gonna be neopets
at 5 p.m pst uh tuesday will be the new season apex launch i
actually played test this oh my god keeping that a secret
for so long and like i actually saw i was they invited me to
see like look at like the updates and everything so i
actually i waited so long to be like i was there i play
tested um all the updates for the new season um and that was
i'm it's gonna be great It's like, it's like, they were,
wait, did they, okay, I don't actually know what's actually
been announced on what, okay, the actual, the Apex players
out there, what did they announce, because I didn't read any
articles, I know they announced some stuff of what's going
to be in the new season, but like, I don't know how to read,
that's my Mr. Man's job, so like, what did they already tell
you guys, because I don't want, like, oh no, Doki, we can't
invite Doki.
anymore because because she she she leaked the fucking apex
patches before it came out oh they showed the perks yeah so
it's like moba ish okay so it's basically like uh the moba
like moba stuff so like you didn't get to pick the the
upgrades and stuff like that and it's it's like um it's it's
very fun it's very interesting and very fun um i was able to
test that uh play test that and i'm so happy it's finally
live uh because i've been waiting to see that on live for so
long anyway but also the best part i can finally play warner
brothers games because what can they do to me
means I can finally play Batman Arkham Asylum which is a
game I've been wanting to play for fucking ever I've never
played any I actually I very much very much enjoy like DC
like I am a like I'm sorry for all you like Marvel fanboys
out there but like I'm not like a I don't really like very
much enjoy I always I talked about this before but I enjoy
like DC comics and the DC movies the animated ones like not
the live action that that shit was just a little too sad
because Warner Brothers is now owned by someone that doesn't
really give a fuck about good movies so the new I can say it
now the new what is he gonna do
do try and delete my channel like they did to wally coyote
um but anyway uh uh for tax breaks uh but anyway yeah like i
really do enjoy the the animated the animated dc movies and
the uh and like just the comics from dc as well so i'm so
happy i can finally play Backman Arkham Asylum is actually
one of the games I've been dying to play for the longest
time No, who can stop me?
He's too busy dealing with like real matters like finding
ways to To get more tax breaks like who the fuck cares about
this random anime girl
Um Um anyway uh yeah, that's gonna be on Tuesday so it's
gonna be like the apex launch and also Batman Arkham Asylum.
And then on February 14th, it's time to celebrate a very
important holiday.
I hope you guys did not forget.
But it is.
Happy Amber's Day.
It's going to be his birthday.
Because that's the most important holiday.
So February 14th is Amber's birthday.
On the 15th, we are going to have an Apex collab with Ditto
and question mark, question mark, question mark, third.
It might be Uto.
I'm not sure yet.
So we're confirming that today.
And then Friday, we're going to be doing Inside the Back
Rooms with Usan.
And finally, Saturday is Members' Garfield Card.
the one to look forward to the most yeah um so it's a pack
week i've i fucking miss streaming so much so i was so ready
to like pack it up with everything and uh i'm just i'm just
so happy to be streaming again it's actually i'm just really
really really really happy to stream again and um and
everything you guys have no idea how much i miss this holy
shit i is just i'm just so happy to be able to do this again
um and i'm so tired too i'm so i'm on like i don't know if
it's like noticeable but like i'm on two cans of coffee
right now i'm so up right now i'm actually so fucked up
right now oh my god i'm oh my god i can play so many stupid
fucking games too holy shit it's it's i can actually just be
like what do i want to play today and be like whoa this game
or that game is actually crazy i knowing what i can play now
and then oh my gosh i'm planning Where my channel is gonna
be heading to like Recently I've been like hitting up some
animators and stuff like that And like I said like shorts
are coming back very very very very soon Just just setting
up the server for my editors And there's so much to look
forward to And then I have to fucking make a proposal thing
for Mr. Man
projects and events I want to do as well so I have to do
that too it's like every day there's so much work and
honestly I oh my gosh I'm the happiest when I get to just
work I I am just such a workaholic and it's crazy I can't
believe my therapist is going to be like wow dokey my
therapist is gonna enjoy hearing this because before all of
this all my therapist heard was me being like I'm so fucking
sad before before all this all he heard was just me being
like I'm sad I'm angry I'm empty inside and now now now it's
gonna be different instead it's gonna be like I'm stressed
There's so much work.
I haven't been sleeping.
Oh my god.
But thank you everybody.
Thank you everyone for all the super chats guys.
And all the people that ordered merch.
Oh I can't.
I'm so.
I'm just so excited.
And I.
I.
Like, I know I keep saying it, but...
It's just giving me so much hope right now.
And it's just crazy.
I never expected to see all the support.
And I know I keep saying it.
But, like, I need to say it again and again.
Because it feels so fucking surreal right now.
And I'm just so happy.
I haven't been happy for a long time.
And I'm happy.
I'm happy right now, but also I have an underlying fear or
two I do I do have an underlying fear and I'm like What if I
fail?
That's scary That's scary Oh my god Um But yeah, anyway
Anyway, I was so I was just So, so surprised like uh like
all the the people like just the talented team that's
helping me too it's it's actually insane and how on top of
things they are oh thank you everyone anyway anyway that's
really all i want to say
oh my god i really just wanted to update you guys on like
what the fuck is going on uh right now and like I felt
really bad that like um I didn't like really I know like I
just got back and then I was like I need a stream I really
fucking need to stream and then I was like okay I finished
the store okay now I can stream because like I was like I
thought I didn't know when the store was actually going to
come back so I was to figure all this out before i put a
stream time because i'm worried that we're gonna still be
working on the store afterwards but now it's done and i was
like okay i need to give them a life update i need to let
them know like what's going on in my life now um but yes i
know on the other side of the world is also lunar new year
right now yeah but yes happy lunar new year on the other
side of the world um i'll be celebrating lunar new year on
my end uh for tomorrow because that's when it's lunar new
year tomorrow so um i can't wait to celebrate all of that
with you guys and that's also when we are uh deciding on
finally the name and also what you guys look like so i'm
going to be drawing you guys as well for tomorrow um and
everything so that's what to look forward to But yes, thank
you again.
I know this is such a super duper, super duper short stream.
But I'm going to fucking pass out.
We're not going to fucking...
I'm going to fucking pass out.
Because those two cups of coffee, it's hitting.
The crash is hitting very, very soon.
It's hitting very, very soon.
soon i could feel it right now and like i need you guys we
are not fucking being free birds because of what the because
of what free birds did to my stream but i was at first i was
like maybe we won't be free birds but now definitely not
free birds um but yes thank you everybody i'm so sorry this
is like an incredibly short stream i did want to do a longer
one today but like you know me drinking two cups of coffee
to be like no i'll be fine the truth is i was not fine it
was not it was not a good idea um but thank you everyone
thank you again for all the super chats everybody thank you
i wish i could thank you guys individually but thank you all
and thank you all for purchasing the merch as well um i
really really do appreciate it um and yeah happy lunar new
year for those who are celebrating it right now and thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank you i really i i
feel like every time i say thank you it would never be
enough but i just want you guys know like thank you hey guys
i'm gonna fucking pass out now as always everyone stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing And if you stayed up for me, head to bed,
because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.